the decision on whether to conclude the  review of the current program and  disburse further financial support to  Greece lies entirely with the Eurogroup  so ultimately with the euro area member  states hence this is a political  decision that will have to be taken by  the elected policymakers not by central  bankers I can assure you that the ECB is  doing all it can to facilitate a  successful outcome if we lose a member  state or if at least there is a default  I fear that all the efforts we have made  to strengthen investment and to support  growth will vanish thank you while all  actors will now need to go the extra  mile the ball lies squarely in the camp  of the Greek government to take the  necessary steps  you